President Biden getting his first
Challenge from the incoming GOP
controlled house go visit the Border
Republicans ready to get tough on the
president's immigration policies they'll
have a lot on their plate every month
there is a new record when it comes to
the number of people illegally crossing
and it is expected to get worse once the
Trump era title 42 ends in December
which may Force the administration to
take drastic measures GOP leader Kevin
McCarthy threatening to impeach Homeland
Security secretary Alejandro minorcas
over the crisis he is inviting the
commander-in-chief to witness it
firsthand
I invited the president go the border
with me I explained to the president he
asked me about the border so I told him
about my current trip
our very own peter Ducey asking if the
White House has checked the mailbox for
Biden's invitation
you know the president's never been down
to the border the possible next speaker
says that he wants him to go with him so
is he going to so look uh he's been
there he's been to the border and since
he took office
since he took office the President Biden
has been taking action to fix our
immigration system and secure our border
we're not seeing that from Republicans
we're not seeing a willingness to work
with us on on you know fixing a
situation that's been around
for decades now instead they're they're
doing political stunts
it's not just concerns down at the
border the crisis could compromise
Airline safety because an air marshal
warning about another 911.
sir please replace the Air Marshals On
the Border stop taking him out of the
skies and let us do the job that we were
trained to do we have been decimated we
have been depleted we're on less than
one percent flights these ground-based
duties if they're pulling us out of the
sky to go to the Border are are just
demolishing our chances at stopping
another 911. Jesse why does the
administration continue to go back to
things that are demonstrably proven
untrue the president has not been to the
Border he one time went to a campaign
event it was a drive-by we know this
this has been out there why do they keep
doing that you'll have to ask the French
binder reader that question I'm not in
her head and neither do I want to be
Dana he's never going to the border with
McCarthy just like I'm never going to a
concert with Greg doesn't matter how
many times he asks I'm not going I've
never asked you have no I would not be
seen in public with you well that's how
Biden feels about McCarthy you don't
want to elevate McCarthy also and say
Okay Kevin let's go down to the border
and see where I've failed the images too
of President Biden with a younger and
thinner Kevin McCarthy pointing at the
failure with flanked by border patrol
agent Sue Joe Biden called whippers
isn't a good look for Joe it's not a
good look for his base his base doesn't
want to see that and to visit the
problem you're kind of acknowledging the
problem but most leaders need to lay
eyes on a crisis it's like if your
basement floods you go downstairs and
you look at the flood you don't tell
your wife your now basements are and
pawn it off to her so
if AOC and Chuck Schumer say well we
gotta have open borders because we need
baby makers to come here
and on the other hand you have Bill
Clinton and Barack Obama and I believe
Nancy Pelosi saying you know what we
actually kind of have to secure the
Border a little bit Joe Biden is going
to have to choose and there is a way to
thread the needle you can have a strong
border and you can have a Humane and
rational Asylum policy I don't know why
that's so hard and I don't think they're
going to get together and do anything
because Chuck Schumer came in even
before the election was finished and
said Mass amnesty for 10 million
illegals and that just poisons the whole
debate for weeks well months leading up
to the election Greg the White House and
majorcus at the homeland security
department they always said the border
is secure the border is secure they said
it declaratively and now you actually
see axios with a scoop last night that
the White House is actually thinking
about a complete overhaul of their
immigration policy why would they do
that I don't know how they can do that
because to overhaul something there has
to be a something and I don't think I've
ever heard an articulation of something
from the administration it would be kind
of cool to hear Biden articulate a
policy or a philosophy regarding the
Border just the Border itself uh you
know should it be strong uh how do you
define strong how are you maintaining
its strength but we've never really
heard that instead we're playing we're
in this mirror verse right a few years
ago it was AOC at the border weeping and
we called that a stunt and now you got
uh McCarthy saying we're going to the
border and then that's called a stun
that's the mirror verse that's when one
party reacts to the other exactly how
the other party would react I intended
to do a Jesse's style relationship
analogy but I realized that it doesn't
really work for him it often gets him
into trouble but I'm going to go ahead
anyway you know the it this Republicans
and Democrats it's like a it's it's a
troubled marriage and the Republicans
are the hand-packed husband right
Republicans are always on the defensive
when it comes to compassion they always
have to explain to the Democrats how
much they care but it's never the
reverse right never the redempts never
have to prove to the Republicans that
they care even though their policies
whether it's the border the economy or
crime hurts way more people than it
helps this is a one-sided marriage and
the husband's always in the doghouse and
he's kept there as a strategy by the
Democrats right proof of that analogy
yes I was trying to do it
Republicans are going to sleep on the
couch yes that's going to happen judge
what happened anymore do people still
sleep on couches
judge what about the Air Marshals being
pulled from their Duty yeah to go to the
Border yeah well you know I think that's
very interesting and apparently it's
something like one percent of the Air
Marshals are now on airplanes doing what
they're supposed to be doing you know
but it's similar to when you took the
border patrol off of really monitoring
the borders so that they could put you
know diapers on babies and so that they
could be babysitters themselves look the
the what's going on with this Biden
Administration is crazy and you know
Greg when you said how there is an
articulation there has to be an
articulation of something well I'm
telling you mayorkas will disagree with
you because mayorkas says he intends to
use the same plan that he used in April
except I looked up his April plan I
couldn't find a plan so you know it's
all about smoke and mirrors right now
the dangers now are to Americans who
will be flying one percent now the
airplanes and believe me the T the uh
the Air Marshals know very well where
the flights are where there could be a
problem and to take 99 of the Air
Marshals and put them at the border for
people who are violating our laws and
illegally entering with no monitoring of
who they are is outrageous it is again
putting the American citizen in you know
in this second class seat but I got to
tell you what's interesting about all of
this is that there are certain people
now who think that it is time to change
the the policies at the border and
they're now looking at the Trump
policies so whether it's uh Department
of Homeland Security and I think
National Security Council and Justice
they're now talking about barring Asylum
for single adults illegally crossing who
have not first applied for legal pathway
or making sure that some of them are in
a refugee resettlement before they
actually access Asylum at our border
what took them so long do they have
enough people to vote Democrat now so
they don't have to worry yeah what what
is driving the Biden Administration to
make this change or to suggest that
they're going to have to make a change
well I think that there's been a huge
surge in the number of Democrats
speaking out against it and part of that
is even though it was a stunt to Greg's
point that everyone just you know takes
their turn I mean stunts we now have
undocumented migrants being shipped to
Northeastern cities right the Martha's
Vineyard thing obviously attracted a ton
of attention it's happening in Chicago
mayor Adams here has said that he wants
to take people but he needs federal
government help to be able to house them
Muriel Bowser in DC is saying it's a
national security threat you can't be
doing this so now you have high profile
Democrats talking about the same things
that Republicans have been talking about
and I think that the Biden
Administration has taken note of that
it's so hard and this happens on both
sides for people to just admit to your
point Jesse that we kind of want the
same thing right there are little
differences in in the level of
Asylum that they would allow that
Republicans would want versus Democrats
how you want the legal system to operate
but generally speaking when you look at
the surveys everybody's 70 plus wants a
pathway to citizenship for people who
are coming here are undocumented they
want them to be able to have their day
in court and the mayorch is four-point
plan from April it did exist
um there were four points I remember two
of them at least which is said we need
more
um tents basically housing for them down
there and to send more judges
that's not enough to solve this problem
and there are so many Democrats on
record throughout the last couple of
decades talking about building a
physical barrier Hillary Clinton was one
of them I came up in the 2016 election
over and over after Donald Trump said
you know they're bad ombres and you know
they're the worst people and then lo and
behold it's not a full wall but there
are Democrats Biden Hillary Bill Clinton
Etc who have been supportive of that so
I think that there is a path forward if
people will agree about the fact that
Democrats and Republicans like the
illegal labor and that's what this
really comes down to I think that it
will never be solved unless people can
get past that and all of those issues
will never be actually solved unless the
border is secure
and you wouldn't need tents or judges uh
additional judges if the Border were
secure yeah well hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else